president biden plans to sign an
executive order today setting a new
national goal for electric
vehicle sales the administration will
also announce stricter fuel efficiency
standards
first on cbs this morning ben tracy
talked to epa administrator michael
regan
about the new efforts to fight climate
change ben good morning
anthony good morning so the federal
government wants the cars and trucks we
drive to be more efficient so they
pollute less
and a big part of these new standards is
to try to get us out of our gas powered
cars
and into electric ones look
the future of the auto industry is
electric
there's no turning back president biden
thinks the road to an electric future
could be a relatively short drive this
sucker's quick
his executive order today says by 2030
half of all vehicles sold in the u.s
should be electric
right now evs make up just 2 percent of
new car sales
this is ambitious but is it realistic
it's both it's an ambitious goal and it
is realistic
when the automakers talk about their ev
sales they frame it
as aspirations as goals
do you believe they're going to do what
they say they may do
you know we hope that they will and we
will hold them accountable
we know that this is where the
technology is headed
we know this is the future of the
automobile industry today epa will
unveil stricter new efficiency standards
for cars and trucks
claiming it will save american drivers
as much as 250 billion dollars in fuel
costs
by 2050 and prevent 2.2 billion
tons of carbon pollution transportation
is the single largest source of
planet-warming greenhouse gas emissions
in the u.s requiring vehicles to be more
efficient
forces automakers to build and sell more
electric models that's how they offset
gas guzzling trucks and suvs
but with the impacts of climate change
now seemingly everywhere
environmental groups wanted the biden
administration to be bolder
the new tailpipe regulations are
essentially a return to the obama
standards
that were undone by president trump dan
becker is with the center for biological
diversity
which took out full page ads urging
president biden
to do more i'm disappointed that that
the president who says
global warming is an existential threat
isn't
putting out a rule that is up to the
challenge of that threat
a lot of these environmental groups that
are very supportive of the
administration's moves on climate
just don't think this is enough we all
have that sense of urgency
epa has a significant role in assuring
that we get the emission reductions we
need and we planned on holding
all of our stakeholders accountable now
executives from the big three automakers
are going to be at the white house later
today when president biden makes his
announcement about electric vehicles
but they're already saying they're
probably only going to be able to do 40
to 50 percent electric sales by the end
of the decade
and they frame that as an aspiration not
a commitment
gail got it ben thank you